I think Bill Buckley was the one who
said that libertarian brew is bracing
when sipped and lethal when swallowed
whole
I'm afraid that's the way too many
Muslims view it hi I'm Nicolas be with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
the founder and president of the minaret
of freedom institute it mad add dean
ahmed dean thanks for joining us my
pleasure okay and I hope to pronounce
your name correctly on the way out if I
didn't on the way in the minaret of
freedom institute started in 1993 and
it's a you helped or you designed it so
that it can bats distortions of islam to
americans or to the wider world while
also explaining to muslims that a kind
of libertarian sensibility and
free-market economics are perfectly
compatible with the quran and the muslim
faith
talk a little bit about why you started
this institute well originally it was in
the aftermath of the iranian revolution
that the experts who had not seen it
coming and and and consequently their
retroactive explanations of it were
totally incoherent i felt that somebody
who actually you know was involved in
and gouge a of islam needed to get
involved in the process of dealing with
these things so i began to write books
and articles and give lectures about
this and in the early 1990s under the
encouragement of a islamic with of a
libertarian think-tank in turkey
realized that it would be very helpful
to those people who are trying to fight
for liberty in the muslim world so we
have an organization like i from in the
muslim world what is the biggest
misconception or fear of a kind of
free-market system the biggest fear in
the muslim world is the association in
their minds of free markets with
imperialism and of course those of us
familiar with the history of libertarian
thought know that the true devotees of
free markets have always been opposed to
imperialism but before starting with I
mean Adam Smith's Wealth of Nations is a
critique of the mercantilism that the
Inc
empire was using to take over many parts
of the world including some muscle
that's right but from the viewpoint of
people who are living in the Muslim
world today what they see are
dictatorial regimes who are often allied
with the West and I see the West coming
in engaging in a kind of neill
imperialism where they're taking out the
raw materials and producing finished
goods which they then sell back to the
countries and exploiting all the
resources and not realizing that what a
true free market they would be allowed
to develop their own industries would
are their Muslim countries that are
doing particularly well and embracing a
kind of free market globalization model
that is working for the home countries
as well as you know growing good
contacts with either the West or the
developed world or other parts of the
Muslim world there are several who have
the one of the most notable successes
for a long time was Malaysia when Anwar
Ibrahim was in the government there and
the most successful one today is
probably Turkey which went from a
situation where they had 100% inflation
rate into a situation where now they've
got a sound currency they've got a
vibrant domestic economy they have trade
with a number of nations and and I have
been doing economically very well indeed
from the other side a lot of Western
Economist's whether they're in Europe or
in the United States often will say well
look you know one of the reasons why
Muslim countries especially in the
Middle East are so backwards is that the
Koran forbids the use of interest or
they you really can't have a modern
banking system and that you know yeah
you know Arabs created the concept of
zero but ever since then they haven't
been able to do basic math how do you
combat that looking towards an American
audience yeah well that is a problem you
know is it was the Muslim civilization
that also created the check so to say
that it's opposed to modern banking is a
little bit limited I have to say that I
personally and I'm a minority among
Muslim thinkers on this point I do not
believe that the Quranic prohibition on
what's called RIBA which is a form of
overcharging
and which has been used to refer to user
e applies to all interest but having
said that I am in the minority it's
interesting to me though that among
economists most are not bothered by this
because a technical prohibition on
interest is so easily gotten around
money being so fungible also it has to
be understood that the prohibition on
interest is not a prohibition on all
interest but only a prohibition on
interest on loans therefore when a
merchant wants to give a Church
surcharge for credit or a discount for
cash that is but according to most
scholars the overwhelming majority of
scholars that is perfectly permissible
so the result is that you can get around
the this prohibition on interest of
loans by various techniques some
legitimate some trickery but an example
of a legitimate method is the so-called
Islamic mortgage you want to buy a house
you don't have the money to buy the
house so you and I become partners in
the house purchase we buy the house
together
you pay me rent for my share and over
time you buy out my share although there
is obviously an implied interest here
it's considered totally permissible
because it is a business deal and so
whatever we can whatever else we can say
there is nothing inherent in the Quran
or in Islam that prevents you know
Muslim majority countries from joining
the world economy well absolutely not
and you can see how many of them have
you know not just Turkey Malaysia
Indonesia but even the ones where they
have a very conservative interpretation
of the religious law like a Saudi Arabia
you know it has a huge Development Bank
and while some people may say that their
methods of getting around the interest
prohibition are trickery nonetheless
yeah let's talk a little bit about a
Syria this is a kind of issue that is
you know on the front burner in the
United States I mean it's and among
libertarians in the United States I mean
it's pretty clear the way that Barack
Obama was talking about wanting to
really engage or you know to intervene
in the Syrian war last August if it
hadn't been for people like Rand Paul
the libertarian leaning Republican we
may well have been on bombing runs by
now
what is the best thing that from your
perspective what is the best thing that
the United States can do visa via the
Syrian war but I think that the United
States has to maintain a
non-interventionist policy in Syria
while at the same time continuing to
exert moral leadership and that moral
leadership can manifest itself in in in
pressure on those Gulf states that have
been putting a negative impact on Syria
by funding well terrorists to engage in
the rebellion I think you have to
understand how Syrian - the mess it's in
today first off the Assad regime is a
terrible regime he's one of the worst
despot in the world and the initial
demonstrations against him was for
peaceful demonstrations were largely
effective because they caused people
from the Assad regime people with
consciences to desert the regime but
when foreigners unfortunately including
the United States and and this also
includes you know Iraqis that includes
Iranians that includes Russians that
includes Turks and the Saudis yeah and
the the cutleries brought but that
intervention on one side or the other
certainly the Russians in the Iranian
supporting I said the cutter ease and
the Saudis you know sending in fighters
to support the rebels and the Americans
and the Germans providing intelligence
support to the rebels all encourage them
to go militant and once they went
militant of course the other whites who
are a minority in this is Assad's group
as well as those groups whom he had made
alliances with like the Christians for
all feel threatened by these extremists
who are coming in to side with the the
rebels and so they've closed forces in
support of the of the Assad regime and
and that is essentially what led to this
horrible civil war so then I mean given
that and they say exert moral leadership
the US can exert moral leadership on
Gulf states or regional allies that we
have there how will that kind of lessen
the violence and lead to you know
a better resolution well that in
combination with improving our
relationship with for example Iran which
fortunately we're starting to do on the
nuclear talks but we have to understand
that Iran is a major player and what's
going to happen in Syria the Iranians of
course are concerned about the Shiites
in general not thought just the Alois
who are a breakaway sect but there are
other Shia in the country and they are
going to I think in fact I attended a
conference recently where I was told by
someone very high up that in fact the
Iranians are eager to compromise on this
issue that their concern is to continue
to have friendly relations with whoever
is going to be the regime in in Syria
and to make sure that the Shias are
protected and they have no particular
support for Assad himself so what they
don't want and what the Russians also
don't want is to see Syria kicked out of
being an ally with them into being an
ally with the United States where as as
far as the despotism in Syria is
concerned they're not interested in
supporting that so if we were to adopt
the position that okay we're not
insisting that we have to put in an
American puppet regime in Syria all we
want to see is that the despot should go
and we are perfectly willing to see
whatever safeguards are necessary in
order for the Alouettes and the shares
and his questions and the Kurds by the
way to be protected then that would be
great
that actually I think both the Russians
and the Iranians would be interested in
cooperating and once they put pressure
on our side he can say you know you talk
to her we started talking about how kind
of capitalism or the mercantilist
version of that is equated in many parts
of the Muslim world with cap you know
with with the West do they also see
communism or a kind of centrally
controlled command and you know command
and control economy as equally as a
Western invasion or an imperial
initiative in their worlds absolutely we
have to remember that the majority
mishil enemy in Afghanistan was the
Soviets and that they were you know
fighting to expel the foreign system
that had been imposed upon them by the
Soviet Union basically at
the Soviets left and Americans came in
they just you know it turned all that
against the well this probably a thorny
or question even in Syria what you know
the u.s. is slowly pulling out of
Afghanistan what is what's the best
thing that the West can do to kind of
you know make Afghanistan a better place
I think the best thing I can do for
Afghanistan and for many other countries
that are in similar situations is to
allow people to people exchanges the the
especially because we have a substantial
Muslim community in the United States
but also there are other communities in
the United States that have expertise of
various kinds that the Afghan Eze would
love to have access to what they don't
want is someone coming in from the
position of power and saying we're going
to impose this on you you know even to
the degree that Afghanistan has moved
towards a more democratic system since
the time of the Soviet occupation it was
through the development of the Loya
Jirga which is an intrinsic inherent
Afghani method of dealing with
governance that even allowed Karzai you
know to come into power so basically I
think that we have to stop thinking it
as a as a nation-state the nation-state
and start viewing people-to-people
relationships right now there are
organizations that are engaged in
helping you know the Afghani is
developed with whether it's schools
whether it's a conflict resolution and
the Afghan ease have because they come
in with respect for the local culture
ganas have never resisted their their
support at least not i mean sometimes
they may exist in italy but that
resistance melts as soon as they realize
people oceans you know libertarianism
seems to be on the rise in the u.s.
younger people seem to be more socially
tolerant and fiscally conservative or
you know however we want to phrase it
are you finding libertarianism is a
gaining a foothold in the either in the
American Muslim community or worldwide
it's gaining not as fast as I'd like to
see it gain but
there are more and more people who are
identifying themselves as libertarians
I'm saying they were voting for
libertarian candidates and and people
who are opening up to if not downright
embracing libertarian ideals
unfortunately the numbers are still tiny
so that and people still are not you
know willing to buy the the whole cake
they are willing to concede increasingly
on point after point and I think that
the question is and to acknowledge the
attractiveness of the underlying
libertarian principle there's still
hesitation as you see with the American
public
that well but if we take it whole you
know what are we buying into sort of I
think Bill Buckley was the one who said
that the libertarian brew is bracing
when sipped and lethal when swallowed
whole I'm afraid that's the way to many
Muslims view it but but again I think
the more time goes on the more they
begin to see the the value of these
ideas all right well great we'll leave
it there
I want to thank it mod Ahmad our Dean
Ahmed he's the president and founder of
the minaret of freedom Institute thanks
so much for talking to us today play for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie